haha the Joe Rogan experience I think we
all need to realize like hey you can't
wait for [ __ ] no cuz this can happen now
that we know that this could happen he
doesn't even feel real here we are we
know it's real right right we know it's
real we know you just got an antibody
test we know we can't really go anywhere
we can't go to restaurants everything's
closed no comedy we know it's real but
it still doesn't feel real
doesn't feel real that's how weird life
is yeah in the moment baby you don't
know what's next
you don't know what's next in the moment
in the moment welcome to in the moment
with Owen and Joe welcome sighs through
fundings I please contact our website
fund a moment into the moment there's a
that's a style of radio that you would
get I was when I was delivering
newspapers I would listen to all things
came was all things - yeah something on
NPR and National Public Radio and they
were so calm yeah the way they would
talk yeah it was so calm I don't know if
was All Things Considered if I listened
to that later I feel like that was way
later but it was uh whatever its it
whatever those old-school type of talk
radio yeah that's what I knew I was
ready to get married when I like listen
in the talk radio I want to hear people
talk I'm ready for a wife bro nobody
gets more riled up than white dudes who
listen to conservative talk radio those
michaelsavage fans those kind of guys
Rush Limbaugh there's somethin let's
think about how that happened like how
did that room how did that one genre
yeah that hardcore right-wing like did
that go real Angry it's like the angry
do it's like oh yeah yeah it's like a
genre of music like you know how there's
like hardcore rap yeah there's metal
yeah you know there's like this
right-wing talk yeah it's like if you
feel is right it kind of is and let me
talk to like NPR here welcome welcome to
our show yeah we're gonna tell you about
a new scientific experiment that shows
the
there are no such thing as genders their
right-wing thunders a construct yeah
there's a way that they talk there's a
calmness to the way they explain things
and lay things out that make you seem
like there's no I'm beg you to ambiguity
there's no question whether or not
they're right yeah and here's why and
then they always has for money yes final
coronavirus did not come from a lab it's
a dangerous conspiracy and here's what's
why we talked to and they always have an
expert are you sure I like it man
I'm coming I'm into I feel good I'm into
it cuz I grew up listening to my
favorite is like hip-hop stations cuz
they're always very excited right put
your heads up like all right and I love
that energy too but then you get to age
like I just wanted some people just
talking just talk normal voice yeah
she's talk normal quiet I want to [ __ ]
you voice yeah that's what that really
is I want to [ __ ] your voice but I'm I'm
low-key about it hello yes hello yes I
love wine I would do if I had to so MPI
would you do it what I do I be guest you
know purposely do like an onion version
of NPR I love it because I'm a sucker
I'm all they're all animals are equal
yeah oh we've talked to some animals yes
we feel like they're all equal I do want
to do a parody of of an NPR show because
they because now they plays like
dramatic music and [ __ ] when they tell
stories like and you'll be listening to
it and then I'm like in then no no I'm
confusing with the daily I'm an NPR show
was radio lab put together by NPR my
borrowing a Daily Show man they be
playing a dramatic music oh yeah and
then Trump Whitney just told me about
the daily she said she's posted so he's
great here are three things you need to
know what exactly WNYC WNYC was the big
radio station of news radio yeah me too
when i was when that news radios have
come new york public radio so it's not
national public hmm
so it's not NPR but it's something like
that it's some kind of pub
greata cousins yeah that's such a great
show you were listening Radiolab no holy
[ __ ] I said I get angry at Bryan Callen
because he would tell me something as if
he had liked gotten it from a book you
gotta go [ __ ] I listened to that same
radio lab try to hit me with some
scientific facts about what happened in
World War two I understand Radiolab too
[ __ ] stop damn it yeah I know Bryan why
you pretending you're right
[Applause]